hello
i'm yang p leo
and today i'm going to be presenting on
a gaussian fixed point random walk
this is joint work with ashwin saw and
mithab sani who are at mit
the key notion that we're going to be
concerned with
in this talk is the problem of online
vector balancing
in this problem
there's vectors v1 through vt in n
dimensions which arrive one at a time
when a vector arrives we want to assign
it a sign which is either plus or minus
one
and maintain a small discrepancy in
other words we wish to keep the quantity
max over all times of the l infinity
norm
of the signed partial sum up to times t
small
online vector balancing or vector
balancing has numerous applications to
various uh fields of tcs
including balancing covariates and
randomized controlled trials or online
envy minimization algorithms
in general algorithmic discrepancy has
been an active field since works of
bonsall and lovett mecca
gave a polynomial time algorithm
to
construct solutions to spencer's six
standard deviation suffice
to get a feel for the online vector
balancing problem i just wanted to give
an example
so
for example
in the first step of an online vector
balancing instance maybe this the vector
arrives minus one one one minus one and
we'll assign it a sine of one and then
we compute the partial sum
then the next vector arrives and we
assign it a sign
and we compute the partial sum
and we keep going in this way and our
goal would be to make sure that every
partial sum doesn't have a very large l
infinity norm
the specific setting that we focus on in
this talk is called the common setting
in the como setting
all the vectors have l2 over most one
and we assume an oblivious adversary the
vectors v1 through vt are all fixed
beforehand and they don't change
depending on the randomness used in our
algorithm
this is a natural setting because the
oblivious adversary model actually
genera generalizes the offline model
where all the vectors are given to the
algorithm up front and we can look at
all of them and decide all the signs at
the same time
additionally the stronger model of
adaptive adversaries emits a square
routine lower bound
because what the adversary can do is
pick the next vector adaptively
depending on the previous vector in
particular it'll pick the next vector to
be orthogonal to the previous partial
sum maintained up to that point
thus the length will grow by one every
step and it'll lead to a square root
lower bound
to describe the previous known results
for vector balancing in the common
setting
it's useful to introduce the comloge
conjecture
this conjecture asks whether given
vectors
v one through v t and n dimensions all
with altoona most one
that there must be signs epsilon one
through epsilon t such that the l
infinity norm of the
signed sum
is bounded by some constant
an even stronger conjecture the
combustion conjecture for prefixes as
i'm going to call it
asks whether given vectors with l2 or
most one the same setting of the
convolution conjecture that there are
signs epsilon one or epsilon t that are
plus minus one such that all signed
partial sums for all the prefixes
also are almost o of one
so it's not known whether either of
these conjectures is true or false
the best known results through the
towards these conjectures
are the best upper bound of o of square
root log t
which works for all prefixes this is due
to banashik
additionally it's known how to give a
polynomial time algorithm
that achieves a square root log t bound
for the total sum so like not all
prefixes but just the total sum of the
homeless conjecture setting
and additionally um there's an online
bound
uh in the commodore setting that
achieves an o of log t discrepancy that
also works for all prefixes
um and this is work of all wise myself
and sony
so
as you can see there's still a gap
between the best upper bounds and
lower bounds for the combos conjecture
and the complex conjecture for all the
prefixes
in particular it's not known whether
there's an online algorithm
that can achieve a square root log t
bound for all prefixes and in fact it's
not even known whether there's a
polynomial time algorithm that can
achieve a square root log t bound for
all prefixes
towards this
here are our results
so we show that in the como setting that
there's an online algorithm that works
against oblivious adverse series and
selects signs that are either plus minus
one or zero
but a small fraction four percent of the
signs at most are zero
and the discrepancy is o of root log t
on all prefixes with high probability
additionally we also show that in the
common setting that there's an online
algorithm against oblivious adversaries
that select signs epsilon i that are
either minus one one or two
that achieves discrepancy o of root log
t with higher probability
once again for all prefixes
additionally both these algorithms
described will run in
nearly linear time in the input
so
the first result on partial colorings
recovers an o of log t bound for online
discrepancy with only minus one one sign
this is because you can
recolor
online the
signs that are colored zero and it'll
terminate in long end rounds and you can
use some concentration bound
however
this these results still do fall short
of matching banashik's oh a root long t
bound online
because of these additional zero or two
signs that we're allowing in these
theorems
however maybe
these theorems at least make me
optimistic that a o of root log t online
and prefix discrepancy algorithm that
only uses minus one one colors is
achievable
and
maybe just towards this intuition
somehow it seems like as long as you add
any little bit of power to the minus one
one siding such as a very small fraction
of zero there's this like two signing
then you can achieve this goal of o of
root log t so at least i'm very
optimistic that an o of root log t bound
with only plus minus one signings should
be doable but we're just missing some
tools to do it at this moment
now i'm going to describe our main
algorithm for proving this theorem
so the first
part
is
that we give this thing called which we
call a gaussian fixed point walk
the precise statement of
that is
we show that there is a markov chain on
r so one dimensional
and the steps are signed either minus
one zero one or minus one one two
and at most four percent of the steps
are going to be zero
and the stationary distribution of this
markov chain is exactly the normal
distribution with mean zero and variance
one
to use this theorem to
give a discrepancy algorithm
here's what we do
for simplicity let's consider the case
where all the input vectors have l2 norm
we're going to initialize a starting
vector w0
to be normally distributed in n
dimensions
when the vector vi arrives for i from 1
to capital t
we're going to first imagine decomposing
the n-dimensional normal distribution
into one-dimensional uh normal
distributions or gaussians in the
direction of the input vi
now we're going to imagine
let's take our
partial sum wi
and imagine which of these normal
distributions it's on
we're going to take one step of the
gaussian fixed point walk described
and then we're going to get the sine
epsilon i from the gaussian fixed point
walk and add it to our partial sum wi-fi
so basically just to describe it again
we're going to decompose the
n-dimensional normal distribution into
one-dimensional slices and then simulate
the gaussian fixed point walk on one of
those slices depending on where our
current partial sum lands on them
to understand why this algorithm works
the main claim is that by induction and
the
stationary distribution guarantee of the
gaussian fixed point walk
the distribution of the partial sum wi
will be exactly n0i the normal
distribution in n dimensions every step
thus for any partial sum i from one to
little t of epsilon ivi
um it's going to be the difference of
two
uh which are coupled
gaussians with distribution and 0i
this is because
the wi
has distribution n0i and the initial
random vector w zero that we picked also
distribution n zero so
um this partial sum is distributed as
the difference
hence with high probability the l
infinity norm of the partial sum is
going to be o of root log t with high
probability
thus it suffices to understand how to
actually build this gaussian fixed point
walk
that's going to be the focus of the
remainder of the top
just to remind
everyone on the goal
the goal is to build a markov chain in
one dimension the stationary
distribution is n 0 1
and the steps are either minus 1 0 1
with a very small fraction of zeros or
minus one two
so notice that because all our steps are
integers we can actually
treat
uh the one dimensional well the the real
um gaussian
as the union of a bunch of discrete
gaussians in particular you can treat
the points f plus z
separately for any fractional part f and
minus one half to one half
for the purposes of the remainder of the
talk we're going to focus on the case f
equals zero and our goal is going to be
to build a markov chain on z now whose
stationary distribution is proportional
to x of minus x squared over two so
basically proportional to the discrete
gaussian on the integers
towards building this
markov chain on the discrete gaussian
it's actually useful to understand first
why no such markov chain exists
whose um steps are size minus one one so
in particular you actually need to allow
a small fraction of zeros or like an
extra two signing or else it's actually
not
constructable um we call this the parity
constraint because
of the following
so let's say that such a markov chain
existed
then notice that because the status has
-1 1 that every step must go from an
even number to an odd number or vice
versa
thus
if the discrete gaussian on z is the
stationary distribution the total even
mass and the total odd mass must be
equal
however you can directly check
numerically that the sum of even x's of
x minus x over two that discrete
gaussian mass is not equal to the sum of
the odd mass
so therefore there is no markov chain
with steps minus 1 1 whose stationary
distribution is proportional to x minus
x squared over 2.
so once we've made this observation
you can actually construct the walk
in a fairly direct way given this extra
power of allowing a small fraction of
zero signs or two signs
so more precisely to construct the walk
we're going to define the following
transition probabilities mx
which is like the moving probabilities
when you're at x
and s which is a staying probability
it turns out that in our walk
on z the only point which ever will
output a sine of zero is going to be x
equals zero no other points we're going
to allow them to stay at the same point
so in that case the total probability
that
um
x equals zero will stay at the same
place
should actually just be the difference
between the even mass and the odd mass
and that's exactly what the staying
probability s is it's the alternating
sum
of the even mass and odd mass
so now given these transition
probabilities we can just define the
following walk
for x at least one we're going to move
plus one with probability mx and minus
one with probability one minus mx
so
for any positive integer you either move
right
or you move left with some given
probabilities you never stay put
for negative integers you do something
similar you move plus one's probability
one minus f of negative x and minus one
probability m minus x
and finally for x equals zero you move
plus one probability m zero minus one
probe with also a probability m zero
symmetrically and you stay now with
probability s so as you can see
only
s x equals zero will stay put or output
a sine of zero with positive probability
so in fact you can prove that
out of walks where only x equals 0 stays
put or outputs a sine of 0
that's such
a transition probabilities are actually
unique
in particular uh as i was explaining you
can derive s exactly as the difference
between the even mass and the odd mass
because only x to the zero stays put
and then from there you could compute
these m x's by just like propagating
outwards and solving some equations so
these are actually uniquely defined and
you can kind of solve for them
algebraically
so
given these transition probabilities mx
and s you can kind of directly check
that
um the discrete gaussian on z
is this fixed
is a stationary distribution for the
walk
there is one piece that needs checking
though just to
formally show that
the walk is well defined
you know to show that m is actually
between zero and one and that s is also
between zero and one
while
uh as stated this can basically be
checked numerically
um there's other instances in our paper
where
you need a more fine control on what m
and s are and i want to explain an
alternate method to understand why for
example
is saying probability s is between 0 and
y
so
first you could just numerically compute
s
and check that it's between 0 1 in
particular s is less than something like
3.7 percent and this is where our claim
that at most four percent of
signs are zero comes from
an alternate way to bound s or to
compute the value of s can be via the
jacobi triple product formula
this very beautiful formula says that
for complex numbers u
and v we have that the sum over all j of
u to the j squared b to the 2j is given
by some triple product
we can apply this to
express the formula for s in an
alternate way
by taking u equals x for the minus one
half v is root minus one in the jacobi
triple product formula to get that s
is in fact the product of
the following quantities as written
so
notice that all the quantities in the
product are between zero and one and in
fact you can show that it converges so
evidently we get that s is
strictly between zero and one
this ends up being useful in our paper
because we also analyze instances where
we want the stationary distribution to
be n zero sigma
for some variance sigma larger than one
and the jacobi triple product formula
actually gives us tighter control
on
what the probability is that the walk
stays at zero
so now i just wanted to conclude with
some comparisons to other works
the work of all wise lou and sonny
gave an algorithm for online discrepancy
their algorithm and analysis were based
on proving that the distribution of the
partial sums wi
were spread by some normal distribution
with covariance
o of log t times i
in some sense you can view this gaussian
fixed point walk as a limit of
this so their algorithm
argued that the distribution maintained
was smaller than a gaussian in some
sense while
our algorithm just directly maintains
that the distribution of the partial sum
is exactly a gaussian
also um later work of chewie gerber
wrigley and turner built a walk in two
dimensions instead of one dimensions um
with steps of length one vectors whose
stationary distribution was exactly the
two-dimensional gaussian
using this they were able to give
um an online discrepancy algorithm where
instead of having plus -1 signings they
had vector signings uh with
two-dimensional vectors and they
achieved
some bounds and discrepancy in that
setting
given our work there's several natural
future directions to explore
towards open problems um some natural
open problems are to ask whether you can
achieve an o of root log t discrepancy
bound with sines minus one or one
or
we can ask the easier problem of giving
just some polynomial time algorithm that
achieves a root log t discrepancy for
all prefixes
additionally
what are any other applications of this
gaussian fixed point walk
and that's the end of my talk and you
can
find the paper at the following link
thank you for
your attention